this is the massive pickup truck Ford
entered in the 2013 Baja 1000 the
terrain of the race is so brutal it's a
victory just to finish this vehicle did
we really wanted to test the durability
of the truck and we didn't even really
tell any of the drivers what you know
this truck was a matter of fact we
didn't even want the competitors to even
see it but Florida engineers were hiding
was that this was no ordinary truck
instead of a standard steel body it was
made of aluminum making it almost 700
pounds lighter the company went to
extremes to prove that light can also be
tough and there is a lot at stake this
is the technology that will be rolled
out in the company's all new version of
its best-selling at 150 when we
lightweight the whole vehicle it helps
it make it stop quicker helps an
accelerate faster and the customer can
also use that capability to carry more
or throw more light weighting has been
and always will be special we've taken
weight out of our vehicles consistently
for the last 20 years until recently
weight reduction technology was focused
on legendary track projects like Ford
gt40 but new government standards are
pushing the company and all automakers
to deliver greener and more
fuel-efficient cars to the masses light
weighting is an essential part of our
sustainability strategy enter the fusion
concept car
the lightweight vehicle behind me is
about 23% lighter weight than the
current production vehicle that's two
car sizes smaller we're looking at mixed
materials steel and aluminum carbon
fiber so it's looking at how these
different materials can come together
and create an optimal solution for
weight but advanced materials cost a lot
more than traditional steel and bring
down the costs of ultra lightweight
components may prove difficult there's
challenges of how to bring this into
mass production we haven't solved all of
the challenges yet but this is where we
see some of the future going this is
what we're working on now for our next
generation of vehicles